i guess the point that i'm getting to
with everything i've been saying so far
is
i'm kind of worried that no one really
cares about their communities anymore
and so it's you know you can do these
cleanups in these in these big cities
but
i don't know how do you feel about all
this moving forward what's gonna happen
um i mean look at the end of the day
i can sleep better at night knowing that
i'm doing everything in my power
to use my platform to make our country a
better place
and you know whether or not i'm
successful at getting others
i know that i did my part you know so i
i can't
judge my success based on the success of
others
i feel good knowing that i'm doing what
i can
to make america great one thing you can
do is when you're walking down the
street
if you see a piece of trash just pick it
up pick it up
yeah it's really fun in front of
somebody yes yeah
and wave it in their face no no i mean
no no wait whatever
just pick it up and take it sometimes
there's not trash cans on the side on
the corners which is a little
unfortunate that'd be cool
but i know it's a lot of upkeep for the
trash people to come to trash people to
come by and like
empty all the trash cans on every city
block but pick one up
just one we can do it singapore does
yeah just yeah arrest people
who litter yeah gum is illegal over
there you can't
you chew gum oh that's bad really yeah
there's no gum anywhere on the sidewalks
because it's illegal
because people just spit it and stomp it
into the ground i think that's a good
thing yeah
if you like it sounds like a leftist
dream right
little effect no no no no i don't know i
don't know because uh
it's almost like right authoritarian you
know cleanliness tradition
serve this you know it's the left would
just like destroy it and burn it down
and then clap and cheer for it like yeah
we got ready we saved the city you know
because that's what they're doing
you know destroying it you know what's
funny to me is that they talk about
tearing it all down and burning it down
and starting from scratch but it kind of
makes me wonder then who exactly is
going to do the upkeep in these cities
nobody who is going to be making sure
that everything's neat and clean and
organized you need someone who's kind of
right leaning to make sure that this
happens
well you could be clean and left-leaning
it's just the problem because the left
we have today is making excuses for the
destruction
look man if you want to be far left and
talk about your communist utopia
all right man i'll have an argument but
if you're supporting the people who are
making everything worse and
burning things down i don't really think
you want to make things better you know
there's a
have you heard of flash graphene are you
familiar with the i don't know flash
graphics
are you familiar with graphene at all
like with trees it's made of carbon it's
pure carbon
okay and it's like a hexagonal lattice
it's a new material you'll see a lot of
it in the 21st century it's incredible
material but you can make it
in a process where they take carbon
trash and hit it with lasers
and you can turn it into this building
material so i think if there's a purpose
for the trash it will excite people more
to go out and get it
especially like the government the
problem is sorting the trash
you know like we could do a lot of
things with plastic we do a lot of
things with paper
we can food food food trash
right we can compost that one of the big
problems is that the food gets all over
everything else and then you got to
clean it and separate it
it's not that easy now we i mean i think
one thing one of the things they do is
like they put all the
they take all the garbage they put in a
dump and they put like grass over the
dump
and then it breaks down like the trash
has to break down and they siphon off
the methane
and use it oh cool those clever things
we're doing to deal with trash
i mean there's also bacteria that eats
it that they found in japan i think
one bacteria in a trash dump underneath
the pile eats plastic right
yeah the future is now man i know i had
a question for you
scott when you what when you first got
inspired
so you when was this
like september 2019. and you were just
chilling at your house or something and
then you saw
what was it like the impact just
watching the tweets much in the social
media you know saw president trump
retweeted kimberly klasik and i went wow
oh my gosh
people don't understand we're all living
in a bubble unless you live in l.a
unless you live in baltimore you don't
understand what it's like to live on the
streets you don't
get it um you haven't seen the tent
cities
and that really opened my eyes and i was
like oh my gosh i can't believe we live
in the greatest freest country in the
world but our people are living
like this and so i said okay i'm going
to do something about it
all right well what do you like so much
about trump
i like that he's keeping his promises i
like that he's
the first president that i can remember
in my lifetime
who has an unshakable commitment
to actually keeping his campaign
promises i mean it's almost like he has
a piece of paper where he has them all
listed and he's just going through and
striking them off
i mean no i like that one of the
criticisms the media has had is that
his call for pulling our troops out of
the middle east was his desperate
attempt to maintain a campaign promise
oh no pretty sure americans like that
he's doing that
gosh president trump stop keeping your
promise to stop
endless wars you should be voting for
the iraq war like joe
biden did i mean he's the first
president something like
excuse me you're gonna have to fact
check me 40 years that hasn't gotten us
into an
endless war that's something that
whether you're republican or democrat
we should all be cheering on that we're
bringing our money
home we're bringing our soldiers home
not spending it why are we
rebuilding iraq iran and afghanistan
meanwhile
our people are living like this in the
streets of valley what if one day you
were like i'm gonna go clean up this
mess
and then as you you know you put on your
apron or whatever you got we got a
breaking news
that the troops had been brought back
and instead of building cities in
foreign countries
they actually were cleaning up the trash
and you could just sit back crack open a
beer put on the tv and be like my work
here is done i'll tell you why they're
built
rebuilding over there in iraq and
afghanistan because they have an
opportunity to start at the bottom they
get
certain people with contracts that are
very that they want to give the money to
that
halliburton for instance big companies
with connections with the people that
are starting the wars
and so they get all the money from the
rebuild whereas we did in baltimore
those companies aren't in baltimore and
we'd have a hard time getting them into
baltimore
i i do think you know when they say
we're spreading democracy
i think that's that's that's one way of
looking at it but i think it has a lot
to do with
it's it's it's like proxy war
influencing it's like
gaining a a strategic location
so that the us can go to essentially
proxy or with other countries
oh absolutely like syria was a proxy war
the u.s and russia essentially
hillary clinton was totally on board
with lag i don't care if we go to war
with russia
so i remember this in 2016 that was the
next question i was going to ask you
hillary clinton was was advised that a
no-fly zone over syria meant
essentially world war iii like russia
would be like that's a that's a war
you know we have a military base there
in um i think it's in tartus
and she was like so what base you know
essentially so donald trump was like no
we're not gonna do that we're gonna try
and negotiate and bring peace why would
we want war
and so you actually had the warhawk
pro-war candidate
and donald trump who was like i'm not
gonna do that so they accused him of
working with russia
but yeah so that that whole thing was
basically this conflict with russia
um the conflict in syria was very much
the u.s supporting those who opposed
russia and russia supporting their ally
in assad
but anyway i bring that up as sort of a
segway you said you you worked for two
years to defeat hillary clinton oh yes
i'm gonna call you i'm out of that i'm
gonna come back to the trump question
cause i do want to get specifics on the
promises thing but i do want to ask like
what don't you what didn't you like
about hillary clinton well for me
i have to make it clear and i mean this
with all due respect to our president
but 2016 was never about electing donald
trump for me it was always about
defeating
hillary clinton now it's changed going
to 2020 and we'll come back but now
now for me it's about electing donald
trump not defeating joe biden
i just thought she was the most
untrustworthy
candidate and i never wanted her to have
power back in the white house i didn't
want her to replace the late
antonin scalia i didn't want her to have
power over all of those
judges and
i'm so glad i helped defeat her yeah
that sounds like uh
regular old politics i suppose yeah you
know and now we're in this area we're in
this era where it's
not regular old politics at all the
weirdest thing to me is the support for
joe biden
because i i mean it's the lies man i
i saw one a friend of mine posted that
they were like
donald trump will increase our military
presence overseas and joe biden will end
it
yeah i know and i was like how dare you
were you around from 2008 to 2016. did
you did you live
for from yeah 2008 to 2016 were you were
you were you
you know like were you alive because i
mean you could watch the news and see
the news reports of what the
administration was doing but these are
the things that they're putting out
and hillary clinton was obama
administration joe biden's the same
thing
i think what they're going for is they
want the same power structure
and they're like what's the last thing
we have this
biden guy it's the best it's the status
quo absolutely
but i really want to point something out
for our mathematicians out there
joe biden has been a career politician
for 47
years which is 19
of our country's history
whoa one-fifth of our country's history
that the united states
first gave its declaration of
independence joe biden has been around
for 47 years as a career politician
is that incredible wow i mean it'd be
almost impressive if you did good things
you know i know like wow i mean it was a
while a while uh
where i was actually excited for bernie
but then bernie sold out you know that's
his
twice yeah yeah definitely twice were
you on board for bernie in 2008 uh 16
rather what was your what was your
feelings about
just the the voting in the political
landscape going into 2016. in 2016
oh gosh i mean you know i was hoping
that we had the the wave on our side but
uh
i mean i it was gonna be close i knew it
i didn't even think that
we were necessarily gonna win i just
never stopped and i hustled and i
grinded
every single day and i never stopped
working uh so i think i kind of deluded
myself into thinking that we were
gonna win um but i mean
the thing that scared me is just the
amount of young people that were coming
over to the leftist ideology and i think
that shifted
and four years i've never seen so many
young people actually coming over to the
conservative ideology
and i follow my my followers pretty
closely you know i try to look at who's
following me
and i'm seeing more and more college
students especially on twitter
and on my instagrams people slide in my
dms all the time and they just say scott
you know i can't be
outspoken like you are which which is a
travesty that we have to say that in
today's society
that people have to self-censor
themselves but all these young people
are coming over and you know what i
think they're attracted to
they're not necessarily attracted to the
politics
i bring them in through the positivity
and through passion
the young kids are attracted to passion
and that leads me to belief
that it's who gets there first is it a
socialist
that attracts the young kids or is it a
capitalist that attracts the young kids
who gets there first who plants the seed
first
and that's going to affect the direction
of our country so that mean that
behooves
us to get there first you know i was
kind of thinking about that
and i i feel like this idea that young
people are socialists
is well i i think it's an illusion
and you know what the best example in my
opinion is tick tock
like you got peop you got these young
kids who are like flashing money not
necessarily
but like it's a thing these vloggers are
like all rich and they're buying
mansions
and they're doing these dances where
it's like we are super rich and we own a
mansion now
like i don't think these people are
bernie sanders supporters you know what
i mean
they're like making videos where they're
making it rain on each other and stuff
murphy was made amazing observation that
in his family he's a communist
in his in his location he was quoting
something oh was he yeah in his like
neighborhood in his city he's uh he's a
socialist
and then in his in his grand country
country he's a capitalist
i thought okay so like when you're at
home you work and then
you buy food and you just give the food
to your family like
you know to each according to their need
right and so that's the general idea
that that actually makes a whole lot of
sense because uh communism works really
really really well
with a very very small group of people
beyond like five to ten people
small group of hard working people and
so kids probably see that
growing up with their family and think
communism is great like that's just why
it's tend towards what you're saying
socialism but not really but it's more
than that
you take a kid who always is being given
what they need from their parent
then they go to school where they're
always being told what to do and given
what they need by the authority then
they go to college
now they're 24 when they are 22 to 24
when they get out depending on which
degree they're going for their entire
lives there was the giant head in the
sky
being like i bestow upon you food for
your labors
thank you giant head tell me what to do
next so what happens when these people
actually go work
i've experienced this where i've had
employees i've hired people
when i was working at fusion and they'd
be like what should i do and i'm like i
need you to book travel how do i do it i
don't know that's why i hired you
oh gosh they're like well i don't know
how to do it either and i'm like okay
we'll figure it out
but you have to tell me no i can't tell
you because i don't know i'm gonna go
make a documentary
you figure the travel stuff let me know
when you're done and they'd freak out i
can't do this
you got to give me instructions nah
welcome to the real world not happening
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time